could they be the most famous weapon in
all of sci-fi lightsabers have been
involved in some iconic scenes in film
and TV history and they make absolutely
no sense
as their name indicates lightsabers
aren't made of a solid malleable
material like real-life swords
canonically these weapons are made of
plasma a real-life state of matter
that's assigned to things like lightning
neon and fire in the real world plasma
is a far more difficult element to
contain than solids liquids or gases but
in the world of Star Wars these
particles have been controlled and
refocused into the shape of a blade for
combat purposes in an article for
space.com the US Department of Energy's
Don Lincoln proposed that a realistic
counterpart to the lightsaber would be a
savior of plasma controlled and shaped
by electromagnetic fields however he
also pointed out that if two of these
Sabers were ever to come in contact with
each other they wouldn't Collide like
lightsabers but instead pass through
each other like air you are unwise
any solid core added to this
hypothetical weapon would have to be
able to withstand the plasma at extreme
temperatures but such a core would also
create more problems the old Legends
Canon of Star Wars provides an
in-universe explanation for this problem
with the lightsaber's construction
explaining that the plasma of a
lightsaber is contained by a force field
however since such force fields are just
another sci-fi Trope it's not a solution
that checks out in the real world
lightsabers are shown to be quite
volatile in the Star Wars story they're
capable of easily severing limps such as
when Luke Skywalker's hand is amputated
by Darth Vader and The Empire Strikes
Back as a result of the intense heat
from the weapon these wounds are
immediately cauterized however some Star
Wars fans have theorized that a
lightsaber should have much more extreme
effects in a 2017 episode of the Nerdist
show because science Kyle Hill analyzed
the potential science behind a real-life
lightsaber wound he speculates that
because human bodies are comprised of
roughly 60 water the intense heat from
the plasma would likely cause the body
to implode in an instant not dissimilar
to the effect of a bomb the fight
between Obi-Wan Kenobi and Darth Vader
in A New Hope is the closest we ever get
to this phenomenon in the movies the
in-universe explanation for Obi-Wan
suddenly Vanishing after Vader strikes
him is that he becomes one with the
force but his instant evaporation might
actually be a more accurate depiction of
what deathbed lightsaber would look like
lightsaber colors have gotten
increasingly more complicated as the
Star Wars franchise has continued at the
start there were only two known
lightsaber colors blue and red
symbolizing the light and dark sides of
the force this change in Return of the
Jedi when Luke Skywalker debuted his
custom green lightsaber since then these
three have remained the most frequent
lightsaber colors across the Galaxy it
wasn't until the prequel trilogy that a
fourth color was introduced on film Mace
Windu's purple lightsaber was created by
the request of Samuel Jackson who wanted
something to help his character stand
out
yeah you might get purple more recent
Star Wars projects have showcased more
lightsaber colors specific to certain
characters including Ahsoka Tano's dual
white lightsabers in the Mandalorian and
Star Wars Rebels and raise yellow
lightsaber in the rise of Skywalker
however if there are this many
lightsaber colors out there it begs the
question of why we usually only see the
main three all Sith use red of course
but for the Jedi there really ought to
be more diversity there have been
various in-universe explanations of how
lightsaber colors come about with some
pertaining to the crystals used in
others referencing the personality of
the wielder whatever the reason you'd
think there'd be a lot more variety than
just a select few special characters
receiving distinctive views
canonically a lightsaber's power is
channeled through kyber crystals rare
items in the Star Wars universe that
possess incredible amounts of energy
lightsabers also have batteries or power
cells to help activate the crystals
which means that like many other Star
Wars weapons they can run out of charge
after frequent use however this rarely
ever comes up as an issue in official
Star Wars media there are examples in
Old expanded universe novels where Jedi
are put in crisis when their lightsabers
power down in battle which happens to
even powerful Jedi like Mace Windu in
the 2003 novel shatter point however in
the mainline movies and shows it's not a
risk that any Jedi or Sith ever really
seem concerned about considering that
batteries and power sources in Star Wars
are Advanced well beyond our own it
could be argued that the loss of a
lightsaber's charge is just a highly
rare occurrence however the discrepancy
between Mainline stories and extraneous
material is still weird
typically lightsabers are only used by
force sensitive characters those who
aren't Force sensitive like Han Solo and
Poe Dameron tend to prefer blasters when
it comes to combat however there are a
few examples of characters who aren't
Force sensitive using lightsabers in the
franchise all Jedi carry lightsabers but
that doesn't mean that only Jedi can use
them throughout the series there have
been various instances of regular people
using lightsabers at least temporarily
for instance Finn uses a lightsaber
briefly in battle in the force awakens
though he's since been confirmed outside
of the films to be Force sensitive the
in consistency of non-force sensitive
characters using lightsabers despite not
having any confirmed knowledge of how
they work dates back to the Empire
Strikes Back but Han Solo uses Luke's to
slice open a Tonton and keep lukewarm
while stranded on Hoth I thought they
smelled bad
[Music]
and then of course there's the darksaber
which has been used by numerous
non-force sensitive characters over the
years from previousla and dinjarin to
moff Gideon and Sabine Wren it seems to
be Canon that anyone can use the
lightsaber but only four sensitive
characters really keep them around it
would make sense to see more Outlaws and
bandits using stolen lightsabers in the
franchise as their incredibly powerful
weapons regardless of their wielder Plus
in the wake of Order 66 there probably
would have been a ton lost across the
Galaxy
since the prequel trilogy lightsaber
duels have become a lot more flashy than
they were in the original Star Wars
films even though the prequels were
still written and directed by George
Lucas the changes in choreography seem
to go against what was established in
the original trilogy in an official Star
Wars featurette Mark Hamill even
confirmed that Lucas told the original
trilogy actors that lightsabers were
supposed to be very heavy requiring two
hands to wield scientifically this
original concept for the lightsaber
makes a lot of sense a 2016 article by
Amanda stahler of the electrochemical
Society analyzed the practicality of
lightsabers explaining that it would
require immense power to generate the
heat necessary to cut through things
like metal and Bones so easily
controlling so much energy would demand
a lot of strength and Canon materials
like Star Wars Rebels have confirmed
that exact idea you're not fighting with
a simple blade as much as you are
directing a current of power for the
most part though this rule has been
ignored lightsabers are generally seen
being wielded with lightness and ease
with some Jedi like Ahsoka Tano even
dual wielding them the concept of a
lightsaber's weight has been explored
further with the dark saber and the
Mandalorian in the book of Boba Fett but
overall the matter is handled
inconsistently within the Canon
there are only a few types of material
that lightsabers aren't able to pierce
in the Star Wars Universe they can
always be deflected by other lightsabers
and materials like armor weave and brick
offer some resistance but the most
significant lightsaber-resistant
material in the series is best car as
depicted in the Mandalorian bescar is a
highly coveted alloy typically used in
Mandalorian armor very few in the Galaxy
are able to forge with beskar with the
armor of the children of the watch being
one of the exceptions at several points
in the Mandalorian bescar is established
to be able to resist both Blaster bolts
and lightsaber strikes even though
there's no metal on Earth that could
resist a plasma weapon of such intense
heat it's also Highly Questionable how
any armor in the galaxy is able to forge
with beskar if all a lightsaber can do
is mildly heated if bescar is truly
immune to lightsaber strikes then how is
a mere Forge able to melt it down to
make it malleable given the importance
kyber crystals have for the creation of
lightsabers it makes sense that they
have a strong connection to force
sensitive people in fact the force user
bonds with the crystal sometimes even
before construction has begun on the
weapon this increases the effectiveness
of the the weapon in their hands however
this begs the question of how multiple
characters are able to utilize the same
lightsaber in the case of Anakin
Skywalker's lightsaber the weapon is
taken by Obi-Wan Kenobi and passed down
to Luke Skywalker in A New Hope Luke
later loses it and The Empire Strikes
Back but it's recovered and given to Rey
in the force awakens the iconic weapon
is destroyed in The Last Jedi after kylo
Ren uses it to kill supreme leader snoke
but it is reforged for the next movie
before it is finally laid to rest in the
Sands of Tatooine for those of you
counting that's several major characters
who all use the weapon at different
times and that's without counting those
who briefly use it like fan or Han Solo
in Canon explanations a character's bond
with their kyber Crystal influences
their lightsaber's color although an
existing lightsaber doesn't typically
change color depending on who wields it
the notion of force bonding with your
own unique kyber crystal is interesting
but it's never been explored in a
consistent enough way to avoid confusion
ever since Darth Vader brandished one in
the original Star Wars the red
lightsaber has been synonymous with the
dark side of the force the same color
has been wielded by every major Sith
character from Darth all and Darth
Sidious do less official Sith like kylo
Ren for lightsabers to take on a red Hue
and Cannon the kyber crystal inside has
to undergo a process known as bleeding
in which an individual will pours all
their negative emotions and feelings
into the crystal however there are
instances throughout the Legends
timeline where Jedi are seen wielding
red lightsabers even Luke Skywalker
briefly wields a red lightsaber in
various new and old Star Wars comics
while some of these instances are no
longer considered canon in the universe
they do beg the question how come there
are no naturally occurring red
lightsabers in Canon when every other
color seems prevalent in Canon sources
there are moments where Jedi use red
lightsabers but only temporarily before
fully embracing the dark side of the
force Anakin Skywalker uses a red
lightsaber to execute Count Dooku and
Obi-Wan Kenobi briefly wields one in
Star Wars the Clone Wars during a fight
against Darth Maul in other instances
characters who defect from the Dark Side
like asajj Ventress keep the red
lightsabers
the darksaber is one of the most famous
and unique lightsabers in the entire
Star Wars Galaxy after a long stint in
animation the blade made its live-action
debut in the Mandalorian where it's
shown to be in the possession of moff
Gideon at the end of season one Gideon
later uses the weapon in a battle with
ninjarin who successfully subdues the
Imperial warlord in the season 2 finale
however din's possession of the
darksaber becomes a dilemma for fellow
Mandalorian vocaton Crees as Gideon
reminds the two of them that the
darksaber is now rightfully dense and
must be won in combat in order to
legitimize bokuton's Mandalorian rule a
yield it's yours
oh no
no
it doesn't work that way the lore
surrounding the darksaber is first
introduced in the Clone Wars and Star
Wars Rebels in Rebels Sabine Wren finds
the weapon but doesn't duel for it the
Mandalorian only makes the rule more
confusing when din loses the darksaber
briefly during season three the creature
that takes it is later defeated by Bo
Katan and then claims that this is
enough of a reason to confirm that the
darksaber now belongs to her however
long before any of this Obi-Wan Kenobi
defeated the Mandalorian previousla then
owner of the darksaber in a duel this
defeat should have made Kenobi the
rightful wielder of the darksaber all
along during Maul's time with the blade
he's also defeated by Darth Sidious
making the whole lineage of who actually
deserves the darksaber quite confusing
foreign